there are a lot of villains in the story
of the student debt crisis it takes
more than one bad guy to get us to a
point where there is now at last count
1.7 trillion dollars in total
outstanding student loan debt 1.7
trillion dollars by the way
is more money than currently exists in
circulation in the united states
now most people aren't paying off their
student debt in cash obviously but
this is just a way of gaining
perspective there is more student debt
than there is physical currency in the
entire country collectively
how did we get here who are the villains
exactly well
the universities would have to be at the
top of the list they're the ones
charging exorbitant tuition fees for an
education that is
rarely worth the cost and even when it
is worth the cost
there is still no reason why it should
cost that much
much also we should blame in equal terms
the government the banks
the public school system for pushing
kids into the university system to begin
with
many parents too must take their share
of the blame for pushing their own kids
into this
and what about the employers who fuel
this madness by requiring degrees for
from
entry-level applicants who will be
performing jobs that do not actually
necessitate
having a degree we talk about all the
jobs that need
degrees and most of the time the need is
artificial there's no reason
there's no real reason why a person
without a degree can't do the job it's
just that the
the employers have put that requirement
there artificially
the vast majority of jobs are learned by
doing
so most jobs are learned in other words
on the job
there's no reason why that expensive
piece of paper should be necessary and
yet employers
often require it out of pure laziness
because it's an easy way to whittle down
the applicant pool without having to put
in much effort so
all of these parties deserve blame then
what about the students themselves
who take out these loans personally i
would much prefer to blame
the powerful and corrupt institutions i
already listed
and the adults who should know better
instead of kids just out of high school
who are too dumb and naive to understand
what they're getting themselves into
i mean everybody is stupid at 18 i
certainly was
and that's a good reason why 18 year
olds shouldn't be granted six-figure
loans in the first place
it's also a good reason why they
shouldn't have the right to vote by the
way
so i'm sympathetic to the idea that many
of the people saddled with this debt
are victims um they were exploited
i don't know what else you can say about
about saddling kids fresh out of high
school with this kind of crippling debt
does that mean that i think the taxpayer
should have to pick up the tab and foot
the bill for student
debt forgiveness absolutely not
you cannot undo the exploitation of one
group
through the exploitation of another if
you want to grant some kind of student
debt forgiveness for some people by
seizing the endowments from these
universities
then maybe we can talk but the only
thing more unfair and immoral than
handing out
massive loans to ignorant 18 year olds
is forcing taxpayers who didn't take out
the loans to pay them back
and the college graduates who who demand
that such a system be put in place
for their sake immediately lose all
sympathy from me
you have all this debt i'm sympathetic
but the moment you point to me and say
and say to the government no
force him to pay it back no more
sympathy
you're no longer a victim the moment you
try to right the wrong done to you by
committing a wrong against someone else
someone steals your car i feel bad for
you you steal my car in exchange
and now you're just a damned thief like
the guy who took yours
that's how that works but there are some
supposed
victims of the student debt crisis who
ought to engender no sympathy at all
from anyone in the first place the wall
street journal just published a piece
yesterday which
highlights this group the headline
alongside a photograph of a man in his
thirties looking sad and dejected
reads quote financially hobbled for life
the elite master's degrees that don't
pay off
colombia and other top universities push
master's programs that fail to generate
enough income for graduates to keep up
with the six-figure federal loans
this is an article all about the
pathetic saps who took out massive loans
to pay for graduate school ivy league
graduate school and now are
as the headline suggests financially
hobbled for life
now something to keep in mind as i read
some of this to you and and this is very
important
the average age of a grad student is 33
and that means that a great many of the
people currently in grad school are my
age or older
so these are not kids these are grown
adults
so here's what the article says quote
recent film program graduates of
columbia university who took out federal
student loans had a median debt of 181
thousand dollars yet two years after
earning the master's degrees
half of the borrowers were making less
than thirty thousand dollars
a year i'm sorry it's not funny but it
kind of is uh thirty thousand dollars a
year that's
minimum wage and you took out a hundred
and eighty one thousand dollars in debt
to go to an ivy league you get a
master's degree
and you're making a minimum wage um
anyway continuing
the columbia program offers the most
extreme example of how elite unit
universities in recent years have
awarded thousands of masters degrees
that don't provide
graduates enough early career earnings
to begin paying down their federal
student loans
recent columbia film alumni had the
highest debt compared with earnings
among graduates of any major
university master's program in the u.s
the journal found the new york city
university is among the world's most
prestigious schools
and its 11.3 billion endowment ranks in
the nation's
eighth uh ranks it the nation's eighth
wealthiest
private school okay pausing for a moment
um
a master's degree in film
for what purpose you you're gonna
get out of grad school at the age of 36
or whatever 35
a broke paralyzed by debt
and then yada yada you're a famous film
director
is that the plan you can't yada yada
through that what's what exactly
fill in the blanks there the problem is
that nobody is going to see a film
simply because the director has a
master's degree
here's a conversation that has never
occurred on planet earth one time okay
again this has never
i'll be the first person to say this hey
man let me tell you about this movie i
saw it's really worth watching it's
great you should see it first of all
the director has a master's degree in
film studies
nobody cares about that nobody cares
about most master's degrees
there are a few useful ones but for the
most part grad school is essentially a
glorified ponzi scheme
so back to the article it says at new
york university graduates with a
master's degree in publishing
borrowed a median 116 000 and had an
annual median income of 42
dollars two years after the program the
data on recent borrowers show at
northwestern university half of those
who earned degrees in speech language
pathology
borrowed 148 thousand dollars or more
and the graduates had a median income of
sixty thousand dollars two years later
graduates of the university of southern
california's marriage and family
counseling program
borrowed a median 124 000
and half earned 50 000 or less over the
same period
then the article starts getting into the
specific sob stories of some of these
pathetic rubes who
mortgage their financial future just so
they could brag about having a master's
degree
i'm not going to subject subject you to
very much of this portion but here's a
taste
quote there's always those 2 am panic
attacks where you're thinking
how the hell am i ever going to pay this
off said 29 year old zack morrison of
new jersey who earned a master's of fine
art in film from colombia in 2018
and praised the quality of the program
his graduate school loan balance now
stands at nearly three hundred thousand
dollars including accrued interest
he has been earning between thirty
thousand and fifty thousand dollars a
year from work
as a hollywood assistant and such side
gigs as commercial video production and
photography
matt black graduated from columbia in
2015 with an mfa
in film and uh 233 000 in federal loans
he signed up for an income-based
repayment plan that leaner that in
leaner years requires no remittance from
him
with interest his balance stands at 331
thousand dollars
mr black a 36 year old writer and
producer in los angeles said he grew up
in a lower middle class family in
oklahoma
he earned sixty thousand dollars in a
good year and less than half of that in
dry stretches
the faculty at columbia was stellar he
said
but he blamed the school for his
calamitous financial situation
he said quote we were told by the
establishment our whole lives
this was the way to jump social classes
instead he feels such goals as marriage
children and owning a home are now out
of reach
okay certainly colombia is partly to
blame for his calamitous financial
situation they're the ones offering this
utterly
worthless product a masters of fine arts
in film worthless
no value and and they offer it and they
make enormous profits off of it
if they were in any other industry
running a scheme like this they'd be
sent to prison
what these colleges are doing is
criminal
they are selling things for enormous
amounts of money
knowing that they are plunging their
students into a lifetime of
debt and they also know that what
they're selling has no value
any other industry you go to jail for
that
but not for universities
yeah i blame them all day long but do
you know who else is to blame for matt
black's
calamitous financial situation matt
black
i mean he said it himself as an adult a
grown adult
he took out 233 000
in loans simply because he'd been told
that it's a good way to quote jump
social classes
he did it because he wanted to feel
smarter and better than you
and now he's broker than you and i bet
he feels dumber too
this is vanity materialism greed
not just on the part of the university
but on the part of these adults who are
buying what they can't afford
hoping it'll be a shortcut to elite
status
the whole thing is a mess from the
undergrad level to the grad student
working towards his phd and finger
painting
it is all to borrow a term calamitous
and it's only going to get worse
you see there is no real remedy
as long as we keep pretending that the
best path for everyone
is to spend the first 35 years of their
lives sitting in classrooms
and accumulating pieces of paper and
letters that they can put next to their
names
the answer is is everyone's talking
about well how do we make it cheaper how
do we make it
more affordable how do we make it so
more people could no no
no no that's not the answer the answer
isn't to make sure
more people can do this really stupid
calamitous thing
the answer is to abandon this path or at
least to let people know that there are
many other paths
aside from this one you may have been
told that you need to whittle away the
first third of your life in classrooms
but the people who told you that were
lying
they were literally selling you
something
you don't need to and most likely you
shouldn't
there are some exceptions but for most
people you should figure out what you
want to do with your life
and then go and simply do it you want to
be in the film industry
then just go and try to do it
there's a really good chance you'll fail
but there's also a really good chance
you'll fail with a master's degree you
still have more debt at the end of that
failure
failure is part of life you want to do
anything worth doing there's
a there's a really good chance of
failure
so just go and do it you might need some
college depending what you want to do
or some kind of formal education outside
of high school in order to fully achieve
your goals whatever they are but
there is a very good chance you don't
there's a good chance you don't need any
of that
and it's almost certain that you don't
need any kind of grad school
that's the truth and if we really want
to solve this problem
we need to start telling it well i hope
you enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content